- Oh!
Nooooo.
No one's gonna notice.
I'm fine, I'm fine.
(sighs)
(squeaking)
(pop)
- Oh my god, did you just pee your pants?
(ominous electronic music)
- Oh gosh,
Uh, no (laughs nervously) I was--
(laughs)
I was washing my hands.
(laughter)
- Boy, you need a diaper.
- I used to think you were
cute, but now you just
peed your pants and I think
you're like a two out of 10?
Maybe.
Boy, bye.
(laughter)
- No.
- Evans peed his pants.
I'm the coolest Zack in the office now.
- Mr. President--
- [Voiceover] I'm sorry son, but today,
you really let your country down.
(barking)
- Has anybody heard
Jay Z's new diss track?
Hova's back in the building, oh my god.
- Not Hova.
♫ Yo yo you crazy
♫ Hell yeah my man Zack
Evans has piss in his pants
♫ Brooklyn stand up
♫ Mr. Pee Pee Pants out here
♫ Pissin' his pants
♫ Can't control, got no bladder control
♫ Ha!
♫ Don't let that chump
Zack Evans ever come
♫ Into the Brooklyn streets
♫ Might just piss his pants ♫
(laughs)
♫ Hova!
♫ What! ♫
(laughs)
(gasps)
(sighs)
- Oh, it was just a dream.
It was just a dream.
(gasps)
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
(gasps)
I actually just wet myself.
(upbeat electronic music)
(squeaking)